et c'est jean vincent brisset bonjour et
merci de répondre à france 24 notre
chercheur associé à l'iris et général de
brigade aérienne et auteur de manuels de
l'outil militaire comprendre le
fonctionnement des armées bonjour on
vient découvrir vladimir poutine ils
appellent clairement l'armée ukrainienne
à faire un coup d'état
elle semblerait
après avoir une première frappe de
décapitations et je pense qu'on constate
que les réactions des militaires
ukrainiens et des milices ukrainiennes
sont extrêmement varié suivant les
différents points du territoire pour les
différentes à et qu'il n'a pu y avoir
beaucoup de coordination centrale donc
l'appel à un soulèvement des militaires
c'est un tentative de retour avec ce qui
est à ce qui se passait avant maidan il
ya quand même eu pendant un certain
temps gimeux au russe à la tête de
l'ukraine mais ça pourrait aboutir
alors totalement incapable de vous le
dire et je pense qu'il faut être très de
20 pour pouvoir le dire mais il ya des
divisions au sein de l'armée ukrainienne
ar je pense qu'il ya des divisions au
sein de l'armée ukrainienne et il ya
aussi certainement au sein de la
population
les différences de sensibilités assez
importante parce que l'époque où
l'ukraine était partie de l'urss c'est
pas si vieux que ça il y a à l'époque il
ya quand même eu des liens assez forts
des deux côtés alors l'autre information
c'est le maire de kiev qui dit que la
ville et est entrée dans une phase
défensive
ça veut dire quoi déjà concrètement
ça veut dire que maintenant et on n'est
plus dans une phase de défense organisée
face à des attaques frontales russe je
pense pour les icaunais en m'occupant à
savoir qu'ils attaquent fois dans la
mesure où les russes n'ont pas l'air de
te faire une inoffensive de très large
ampleur un peu plus tôt des offensives
ponctuelles pour que nos objectifs
ponctuelles défendu par des des troupes
qu'il comme je les dis ne sont pas
coordonnées semble-t-il donc à ce
moment-là on appelle à la résistance
générale on sachant pas bien qui va
suivre qui va pas suivre qui a des armes
qui a des codes commandement qui est
allé sympathie dans un sens en tout cas
on est dans une stratégie d'encerclement
les troupes viennent du nord du sud de
l'est 2
de l'ukraine
l'objectif là clairement il ya plus de
doute c'est de marcher sur kiev
alors je suis pas du tout persuadé pour
le moment il ya une stratégie
d'encerclement certainement cette
stratégie de poids de prises de position
lourd de vialas crime et qui à
la partie russe face aux deux basses à
l'est et au nord via la biélorussie
il ya là une taille des mâchoires de la
thonaille sont marqués maintenant la
langue centrale qui se dirige vers kiev
et qu'ils arrivent vers d'autres points
comme au nord on a beaucoup de mal à
avec de la formation auprès mardi cerner
l'ampleur est savoir ceci tu veux en
suivre pour prendre le contrôle savoir
si c'est une offensive simplement pour
prendre un certain nombre de points
sensibles où ça nous mène tout
maintenant détruire un certain nombre de
points sensibles pour empêcher les
ukrainiens s'en servir je pense à
déposer commandement à des postes de
gouverneur le point fort des russes
c'est leur aviation qui a fait un
carnage en série à partir de 2016 là
visiblement
voilà l'aviation les les bombardements
semblent appuyer les soldats au sol
alors il semblerait que l'aviation russe
est passé dans l'aviation les pistes qui
vont avec aussi
réussi à créer ce qu'on appelle un
environnement permissif c'est-à-dire a
réussi à empêcher la crème de se
défendre aussi bien avec des moyens
solaire devait moyens et ar donc elle
n'a plus l'aviation dufresne d'appui
l'aviation elle semble ne plus avoir de
missiles de défense antiaérienne donc
l'aviation russe ses avions de chasse
nos six hélicoptères ont le champ libre
et il semblerait qu'ils aient même eu
des à poser d'assaut c'est à dire qu'on
arrive à avoir des avions de transport
avec des soldats avec des haches pizza
ce qui arrive à se poser sur les
aéroports de crédit qui leur est donc ça
ce problème là j'ai terminé pour les
pour les russes ils ont la maîtrise à
peu près totale du ciel et vont ils vont
en profiter est-ce qu'ils en profitent
pour appuyer pour ceux là si je suis
patient pour une fois que ça soit une
offensive de grande envergure s'ils sont
deux offensives le petit commando il ya
besoin quelquefois de se faire dégager
s'ils sont faire partie de se faire
dégager par de l'aviation mais
l'aviation mais ne sera pas le rouleau
compresseur qui arrive devant mais ça
vous ça ressemble à quoi une guerre
éclair ce qu'on est en train de vivre ou
pas deuxième jour bon on attend les
chars russes qui sont toujours pas
arrivés sur maïdan ça ressemble à quoi
ça ressemble si vous voulez toutes ses
frappes aériennes et que ces prises de
points sensibles c'est ce qu'on appelle
une frappe de décapitation c'est moi ça
me fait penser un petit peu à ce qu'on a
fait en des billes en 2011 c'est à dire
qu'on a cassé et l'erreur de l'armée
libyenne et là le but était de casser
les reins et la gouvernance de l'armée
ukrainienne et du gouvernement ukrainien
en utilisant des cap sur des points
sensibles
ça me semble être ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle tout en bloquant en
ajoutant un certain nombre de présences
au sol que les qui n'avait pas été fait
par la coalition contre la libye mais
la brutalité est plus forte avec ses
propos sol mais se trompe au sol me
paraissent encore une fois par une
envergure de grande ampleur aux attaques
on ne va pas revenir sur le débat l'otan
donc ne peut pas intervenir en ukraine
le non plus les européens pareil donc
les ukrainiens sont livrés à leur sort
mais les occidentaux depuis plusieurs
mois ont livré des armes à kiev à
volodimir zelensky c'est quoi comme type
d'armement des armes de défense
alors il semblerait enfin l'armement le
plus significatif dont j'ai compris
qu'ils avaient été livrés ce sont les
missiles jav lin sont et missiles
antichar qui pour la particularité de
survoler le chat et de l'attaqué à la
verticale là où les plus sensibles et le
moins blindés c'est à dire au niveau de
sa tourelle on a commencé à voir les
premières photos de chats qui ont été
modifiés en fonction de l'expérience qui
avait déjà été actif par les russes en
syrie avec un espèce de petit toit en
ferrals qu'il suffit pour faire exploser
le be still et lui faire payer votre
avant qu'il ait percuté la tour n ont
que faire perd son efficacité parce
qu'il faut pas oublier non plus que les
russes ont gagné énormément d'expérience
en syrie et qui met cette expérience en
partie
merci beaucoup jean vincent brisset de
nous avoir éclairé je rappelle que
d'être chercheur associé à l'iris
général de brigade aérienne et qu'on
vous doit manuel de l'outil militaire
comprendre le fonctionnement des armées
merci à vous